*bâillement*
Je baille !
C'est à cause du changement d'horaire.
La nuit a été plus courte.
Mais pourquoi baille-t-on au juste ?
On ne le sait pas précisément.
Selon certains spécialistes, le bâillement permettrait d'augmenter la circulation sanguine
pour refroidir le cerveau, histoire de nous réveiller.
Ce que l'on sait en revanche,
c'est pourquoi nous mettons la main
devant notre bouche quand nous baillons.
Ce geste remonte au Moyen-Âge.
Pas pour protéger nos voisins d'une haleine fétide.
C'est une superstition pour empêcher
les démons de glisser dans la gorge
et l'âme de s'échapper.
Quoi qu'il en soit, j'espère que cette "capsule de déconfiné" ne vous aura pas fait bâiller d'ennui.
A demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confiné mais on reste en lien !
*bâillement*
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors, pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné"
abonnez-vous et activer la petite cloche
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain!